شدد رئيس الوزراء الاثيوبي ابي احمد على
ضروره حل الازمه بين بلاده والصومال بطرق
الدبلوماسيه من دون مشاركه اطراف خارجيه
في اول تعليق على الازمه بين اثيوبيا
والصومال على خلفيه اتفاق اديس ابابا مع
اقليم ارض الصومال غير المعترف به للحصول
على منفذ بحري لاثيوبيا اكد ابي احمد ان
بلاده لن تنجر الى صراع مع
الصومال كلما طرح ننا احتياجنا لمنفذ بحري
يتم تحويل الامر الى اجندات للحرب مع
ارتريا والصومال بهدف حرماننا من الوصول
السلمي والامن للبحر الصومال لها مقام عال
لدى اثيوبيا فهم اخوتنا وجيراننا واثيوبيا
ساهمت اكثر من اي دوله في العالم في تحقيق
الاستقرار في الصومال لقد قدمنا ارواح
الالاف من مواطنين لاجل ذلك ومن الضروري
حل الازمه بحكمه ودون مشاركه اطراف خارجيه
ترغب في جعل الصومال منطقه صراع لكننا لن
ننجر الى صراع مع الاشقاء في
الصومال